Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
We’re currently working on the sport and
recreation plans for the Kaiapoi East Regeneration
Area and have been meeting with the sports
clubs that are going to be located here.
During this design phase, we’re looking
at the positioning for the sports fields,
car parking, club room facility, public toilets
and also spaces for the bmx track and dog park.
The Kaiapoi Food Forest was a popular request
during the development of the Recovery Plan.
In September, a number of mature fruit trees
from empty sections in the Regeneration areas
were relocated to the food forest site.
And then the community-led project really
got off the ground with the opening
and community planting day.
It was the number one request on all the community
consultation and it's just great to see something
visible and above ground happening.
It's always more exciting to plant trees than
put sewer lines underground and the community
have turned out in force and it's all go.
Many of the trees planted were donated from
groups and tree-nurseries located from all
across Canterbury.
Organisers were stunned by the support shown
by the community.
We've had amazing support for the Kaiapoi
Food Forest.
So many groups have come down, so Kaiapoi
Garden Club, we've got Cactus - the leadership
programme from Kaiapoi High.
We've got the Mayor, we've got councillors,
we've got,
what, probably 150 odd people
down here I'd imagine Lesley?
Dude, I'm running out of fingers to count.
Although a large amount of work has been done,
it will take years
for the project come to full fruition.
The Food Forest is being planted in a layered
system with larger fruit trees sheltering
smaller bushes and plants.
It's quite a lot of intensive work initially,
for the first couple of years.
So you set that major fruit tree, or nut tree
and then underneath that you put a smaller
fruit tree and underneath that you put raspberries
or berries.
Then underneath that, root crop and ground
cover, so you've got five layers over the
top of each other.
And the food forest, isn’t just about providing
food, it’s also an opportunity for the community
to connect with one another.
I think this is something that's lacking.
It's people getting out and working with each
other and spending time with each other.
So for me, it's not necessarily so much about
a food forest, it's about everything else
that goes with it.
It's incredibly humbling and what an amazing
community to be part of.
Thanks everyone.
The Food Forest will really be coming into
its own about March next year, and the public
will be able to come down and enjoy it.
We'll be installing a new pedestrian gate
next to the existing gate on Cass Street.
In the next update we’ll meet Gavin Lake,
the Council’s Roading Recovery Programme Manager
He’s supervising two roading projects that
kick off in January - The new road link in
Kaiapoi East and in Kaiapoi South, the repair
of Courtenay Drive, and parts of
Charters Street and Wyber Place.